qu'est-ce qui se passe bah j'aimerais
qu'il y a un bel étalon qui soit avec
nous un homme de 25 ans bien baraqué et
tout pendant qu'on fait l'amour ah bon
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'il te
fasse bah j'ai pas de l'air de
l'éventail ok bon ça va bah monsieur ben
Toussaint on y va il commence il
positionne le mec de 25 ans devant lui
avec cette éventail il lui dit écoute je
fais bien le jugement tu vends du vent
ma femme elle a envie d'être au frais ok
il y a pas de problème et tout et
comment ça par la toucher etc ça y va et
puis là elle lui dit écoute ça marche
vraiment pas mais je comprends pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe je sais pas je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'on switch ah bon
mais pourquoi qu'on switch et ben parce
que je sais pas viens on essaye je te
dis l'homme de 25 ans prend la place de
Monsieur ben tout ça en Bensoussan il
prend l'éventail il fait de l'air un
courant very passe il passe et là hurle
ah
incroyable le mec il lui dit tu vois
c'est pas si compliqué de faire de l'air
[Applaudissements]